super bowl 55 kicks off tomorrow under a
cloud of mystery
kansas city chiefs assistant coach britt
reed the son of the team's head coach
andy reid was involved in a car crash
near the team's training facility late
thursday night
kansas city police say two young
children were hospitalized as a result
of that crash
according to a search warrant obtained
by our kansas city affiliate
kc-tv reid told police he had two or
three
drinks before the crash jamie yukas
is in tampa where tomorrow's
unconventional super bowl will be
played jamie good morning to you good
morning jeff the chiefs are scheduled to
arrive here in tampa a little bit later
on today
no word if brit reid will be traveling
with the team and it
is highly unusual that a super bowl team
is arriving in the host city
the day before the big game that late
arrival is just one of many changes
due to the pandemic when america's
biggest sporting event kicks off
tomorrow
expect to see masked fans socially
distanced in the stands of raymond james
stadium
and that's just some of the precautions
every fan will be still have nobody
seated in front of them
nobody in behind them as well as wipes
and hand sanitizer in restrooms which
not only have
physical distancing but touchless it's
the first ever cashless super bowl
the concern over crowds here is
amplified tampa isn't just hosting the
game
it's hometown team the buccaneers are
playing in it
tampa mayor jane castor can the city
handle this
we can handle it it's imperative that
everyone understands the level of
personal responsibility and that they
have to wear
masks nearly 44 thousand of these
cardboard cutouts will help keep the
fans in attendance
maintain a safe distance invite each
member of your team
to be our guest at the super bowl that
includes about
7 500 vaccinated healthcare workers who
are special guests of the nfl
including married doctors jacob and
alicia salman
tom brady is like the one player i'm so
excited to see he went to university of
michigan
so i grew up watching him and it's just
you know i never thought i would
see him at the super bowl the bucks
quarterback is one thing that won't feel
new to viewers
tom brady is playing in an unprecedented
10th super bowl
but is first with tampa bay and brady is
trying to help his coach bruce arians
win his first championship how are you
feeling about it
i feel fantastic it won't sink in for
tubby until
the end of february but it hit me
when i was holding the halos trophy that
we're going to the super bowl it was
really cool
with the country suffering from the
effects of a pandemic and political
division
arians hopes tomorrow's big game can be
unifying for the country
do you feel like this game can bring us
together
i hope so i really do i just wish there
i wish we could fill the stadium
hopefully next year we'll be back to
some fortnite at some of normal
uh but this year yeah i'm hoping it can
it can bring back a lot of people bring
them back together
i think a lot of us are hoping that
those lucky enough to get tickets say
that they plan to be safe they all plan
to wear a mask
and the nfl does plan to make that easy
for fans they're going to be handing out
these kn 95
mass as people walk into the stadium on
sunday
jeff jamie uh your vikings aren't there
unfortunately neither are
neither are my bills or my lions
lions or michelle saints so
we assume there's a lot more tampa fans
obviously there since it's in tampa but
what's the mix of fans in in the city
right now jamie
you do see plenty of kansas city fans
here they actually added another flight
from kansas city into tampa to make sure
that fans got here
to the game but i can tell you there are
a lot of bucks fans
walking around as you said because the
host city is also
in the super bowl itself so uh there's
plenty of people walking around i think
there's gonna be a lot of cheering
for the tampa bay bucks on sunday i was
just go ahead
i was just jamie i know that you there
were gail and tony and anthony got their
cutouts
in the stadium did you get yourself one
at least
no i didn't and i want to know what's up
with the pink jamie
i gotta know this i like it looking good
in the pink it's good
it's florida it's nice second day of
pink
it's february in florida if i can bust
out the pink i feel like i'm doing a
good
good thing here all right jamie thank
you coverage of super bowl 55 here on
cbs begins tomorrow morning with a free
game at 11 30
eastern game time is six o'clock eastern